if she can't get anything out of it
right she won't side with me
she'll betray me we um you know i foster
dogs yeah
i heard some dogs barking so i was
fought i
fostered three puppies and
um i i haven't had a foster fail
in a long long time just because i'm
like i can't have another animal i just
want to continue fostering but these
[ __ ]
convinced me that we had to keep the
last puppy that's not
it oh wow that's exactly what happened
you you know it's so
you wanted to keep two puppies say
things
so conveniently oh my god the saint all
right
let me tell you something honey woman
i liked honey butter all right honey
right as soon as we got the puppies you
kept going oh look at that one that's
the one
you have you kept saying if i were to
keep one of them
it'd be that one but that's just in
passing i say that about all my
stuff i love all my stuff yeah so
there we have one that we kept called um
his name is stub
stubs stubs he's stavros but he's stuck
he's got like little legs and he's
really kind of dumb
and but innocent but also cute so he's
so sweet right
stuffed roses and as soon as we got
these things
sh you kept saying oh these puppies are
different these are gonna be harder to
give away
right yes because they're and i'll say
it like i've
we've fostered a lot of puppy litters
before and these guys were
were different to me they were not as
destructive
they were so there's something their
essence was different their essences
were
all right so we give away mick the third
out of we have three yeah
as soon as mick goes right it broke your
heart you didn't cry
but it was broken right jules didn't oh
okay
so now i'm in oklahoma right and i go
get rid of these [ __ ] puppies when
i'm out of town because i don't want to
cry
i don't want to make a fuss i just get
the [ __ ] in my [ __ ] house
right so then you call me
you on the day the adoption day
because billy day before and stubs were
gonna no no it's the same day
i promise you i called you a couple
hours before they were
their new adopters were supposed to pick
them right and she
acted as if all of humanity was wiped
out i mean she was like
in tears um
right and i'm like i know but you gotta
[ __ ] do it woman
yeah i did relax okay let me finish my
[ __ ] thing
all right and when your eyes get crossed
i i don't like it
it reminds me of my mom when i when i am
crossed my eyes cross
i know your eyes crossed and that's what
my mom's did and
i know that you guys the lee thing this
is what really bugs me it's like this
yeah yeah we do the job thing yeah yeah
that's what we do
and it's it but you cross so stop
crossing okay i'll uncross it all right
uncross your eyes
so she um crying right and then i go
i'm saying no it's hard and then so
a couple hours later they get rid of
billy billy goes
and when billy goes right juliana
julianna emotionally has a
breakdown has she reacted like this ever
before yes all of our fosters
not like i don't think like this yes
babe she cried a lot but you never
caught cry i
never cried like you don't cry like that
no i don't cry in front of you guys i
cry privately in the shower
oh really i do all this what are you a
sergeant in the military that's what
daniel craig does in james bought
because i'm thinking you give orders on
the on the plane but
now we have stubs left subs is left and
somebody wants to come over
to pick stubs up and they never showed
up they backed out and then what
i called you and what did you say it's
god's will no no that's not what
happened that's exactly what you said
that's let me stop for a second all
right you go
shules wants to ask you something
you not say that i did say that um so
here we go see what i mean
jules is crying do you understand what
i'm saying if you only heard it from her
point of view
right it would be the false story okay
okay but
listen to it
one whole week leading up to this by the
way
you guys have been begging me to keep
both puppies no no no yes jokingly
not joking is it joking no you never
joke about that [ __ ]
okay but go ahead so that the doctor
doesn't show up jules
looks like i mean she looks like she she
keeps uh her face
looks really sad yeah can we keep
she goes there she says this can we keep
giving is that what it is
that's what she says
and i go you know what's god's will then
i say it's god's will
if the lady didn't show up to get the
[ __ ] dog yeah right
it's god's will but today i was alone
with the dog all four of them
and i'm i'm just literally going what
did i do
oh the [ __ ] puppy pissed all over our
bed
no he didn't he didn't piss on the bed
just once yeah all over the bed
he's it just once is like
good ratio so far and the [ __ ] puppy
i'm telling you right now putting up
great numbers this pop
this puppy he's cute right
and he he he has i have moments with him
but i don't think he likes me that
much because when we're at bed i brought
him in the middle between us
he'll just get up and just go on your
side
he doesn't want to [ __ ] with me that's
not true he slept on your face the first
day that's the first day but then you
realize i don't like the breath is not
good
mine is better yeah i think that's what
is my breath yeah you smoke cigarettes
yeah i think it's my breath his name is
stubbs
officially government name is dav rose
and we're very very happy to have him he
is very
he's a goofy goofy smartest but very
sweet can you promise me this though
what no more no more what no more
fostering nothing
we still have a foster youth that's why
it's like we have this gigantic gigantic
dog dog in the house too downstairs do
you guys want to meet him
yeah sure so anyway we have a german
shepherd he is one of the sweetest dogs
in the world he's just so
tender and kind and um
if anybody that lo if anybody out there
loves a german shepherd and
wants one and this and one of the
sweetest ones on planet earth um
please if you live in the la area
contact us
our may day rescue or media rescue
because we um
we just love this guy you know and it's
just uh it's a sad situation and we're
just trying to help what are you doing
at uh david spade's house
come on man no what were you doing at
david spade's house we don't know what
he did
with my son you guys did you really get
together to watch that god-awful fight
no because we just well he because first
of all he couldn't get
he has a computer right a laptop he's
like how do i get
this onto the tv and i'm like you don't
know how to do